we all get together Oh
feud what feud on Tuesday the
kardashian-jenner 'he's got together to
celebrate caitlyn jenner's 70th birthday
with a family dinner yep Kylie kendall
Kourtney and Kim were all there for the
birthday bash at Nobu in Malibu
and naturally in true kardashian-jenner
fashion they documented the whole
shebang on social media
[Music]
are you ready as far as we can tell this
is the first time Kim and Kourtney have
hung out with Caitlyn in years or at
least shared it on social media the only
sister not in attendance
Khloe while it's unclear why she was
absent from the birthday celebration it
could be because she was working earlier
in the day she posted this message to
her insta story telling fans
she'd been shooting a commercial all day
but she also posted this ominous message
to her feed during the party time is
everything we have and don't the
Kardashians have had their ups and downs
with Caitlyn over the years a lot of
which has been documented on the
families reality show I just really feel
like over the last year and a half we
certainly have grown apart day after day
after month after month nobody calls
Caitlyn didn't help matters when she
published a tell-all memoir in 2017 that
included some controversial claims about
Kris Jenner all through the book
Kris knew Kris knew before I even made
love to her I'm like what to sell in the
book you're gonna make something out she
was insinuating that like mom took the
check and pocketed it it's insane mom
that's insane
life can change on a dime and you just
have to I just have learned to be ready
for anything and just be there for my
kids and in 2017 Caitlyn told Andy Cohen
that she hadn't spoken to Chloe in years
she doesn't wanna talk to me that she
doesn't yeah yeah what she hasn't talked
to me in like two years she hasn't but
when Kim Khloe and Kourtney appeared on
watch what happens live in January they
seem to suggest they were all on good
terms with Caitlyn we saw her on
Christmas Eve I know her on Christmas
Day it's like new year and drama-free
that's like our motto this year and in
May
we opened up about the status of her
relationship with Caitlyn on the divorce
sucks with Laura Wasser podcast I'm fine
with Caitlyn I think we've really come a
long way it was a struggle I think for
all of us not because she was
transitioning I think from just how it
was all handled on Monday Caitlyn's
actual birthday she shared this pic of
her posing in front of a ton of flowers
and she revealed on her instace Tori
that they came from all of her girls Kim
Kourtney Kendall Kylie and yes Khloe too
and that is how you drop the mic people
no more drama to see here pack it up and
go home of course
et will be right here to make sure that
you're keeping up with the Kardashians
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Holly Stephens
bye for now
[Music]